i want to start with what tv series
would each of you like to guest star on
oh it ended but new girl i love new girl
with
like that it's i love it and it's so
funny it's like
pure top comedy so if they were still
around then i would
for sure be on it um the boys
the show about the superheroes but
they're evil
dang i watch i watch more movies
officer parks and recreation are my two
favorite shows but they're over
yeah well we're on division
yeah i love wanda vision it's like so
smart and i would love to be on that too
yeah any marvel series yes right
the next question that i that everyone
gets asked is what movie or movies do
you think you've seen the most
direct to white chicks is one of my
favorite movies to watch or else
like silence are the lambs oh
wow ichi ichi i'm gonna say ichi
[Laughter]
these are all these are all excellent
choices for nightmare before christmas
sorry okay yeah yeah that's a good
that's a good one too
yeah i like that uh jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you guys
for each of you um what do you think
people would be surprised to learn
about the making of an animated movie
how
awkward it is at times like for the
actors alone
we have to you know when you're riding
specifically this movie when you're
riding the horses
it's just you just breathing profusely
into the mic and like pretending to be
riding a horse
and it's just awkward
i don't know how to describe it better
but um i used to i would get a little
lightheaded too because they'd be like
okay you're still riding
the horse and you're still riding the
horse and you're still riding the horse
i'm like
they're like do you need water yeah i do
actually
one second
it is quite odd i mean yeah i think we
all
agree with that because we all had to
kind of have to do uh the same thing in
that way because uh we had a lot of uh
crazy adventurous scenes so we had to do
a lot of those efforts
so yeah and it's definitely the best
whenever you're watching the little
clips and
uh the horses are bald
because they haven't animated there yet
oh my gosh wait do you know they animate
the clothes of the characters
but even like the undergarments so i'm
watching like the
it was maybe one of the final versions
of the movie
but some of the scenes weren't animated
so i'm like watching it with my niece
and then all of a sudden cora shows up
she's like almost naked
she's wearing she's wearing like her
undergarments and back in the day
that's like you should you can't switch
on nobody that and by the way she's
built like the mom from incredibles
she is curvy right don't let those big
dresses fool
i you that's that's very funny that i
did not know what did you most respond
to
with the script and story of this movie
was there something that really
resonated with you
there's so many things i resonate and
connect with in uh into this story i
love uh
just prue's relationship with her father
and how
they both love the same thing they work
just as hard on their passion their
craft and
um no me and my me and my father do the
same thing i mean we
own our production company so we're
always in our like game boss mode and we
both have leo energy we're both leo so
it's you know how wild that could be
so um yeah it's uh it's pretty funny and
even even my mom too like she's a
tourist so we kind of all have that
energy so
um yeah and then then again what i also
love too
is just the friendship uh part of it all
is um
it's pretty sweet too i'm in a i'm in a
trio myself so
um being a part of something that is
super sweet with three girls is pretty
cool i just think this movie at the at
the
core of it is just heart it's not any
like money-making
thing or stunt that the studio is
pulling and forcing a bunch of writers
to come together and make it's people
who actually wanted to make this movie
who love horses and love friendships and
have a lot of lessons
to teach and bring to the table and
that's what initially drew me to this
project was the people behind it
they didn't even show me a script i just
heard their pitch and
they said how much they saw lucky in me
and i was like
bet i'm sold say less
congrats on the movie and i hope you
guys all have fun speed dating the rest
of the day